this might look like your typical
Western background but it's actually an
abandoned set of a video game the
Western was easy to accomplish here in
New Mexico we have the sets we had the
Cowboys we had the horses we had
everything we needed including a great
villain Mad Dog McCree
there had never been a live-action
interactive video arcade kids until mad
dog came along
[Music]
the year was 1990 the dawn of a new age
of video games was about to begin our
cage had small but powerful rivals in
the living room the smallest the game
boy born in 1989 the scariest the home
console Sega 16-bit Genesis and
Nintendo's Super NES now anyone could
play high-end video games anywhere they
wanted our cade makers had to step up
and utilize their main advantage more
storage space that could hold hours of
video footage instead of
computer-generated graphics they used
live action live dialogue and live
actors the type of production values
that console games couldn't touch which
brings us back to where we started
New Mexico a place where a one-of-a-kind
experiment changed the video game
industry forever the props from that
first live-action game still remain in a
dusty warehouse outside Albuquerque I'm
Dave Roberts and I was director on Mad
Dog and Cree
it was our first entry into video games
these are the thick dynamite sticks the
makers of Mad Dog weren't always in the
business of making video games they
actually got their start making police
training simulators we shot things that
police would encounter during their day
they put it up on a big screen and a
police officer would walk into the room
he would have a pistol that had had a
laser put into it and he would respond
to whatever was happening on the screen
once we knew how to do that it made it a
little easier to do Mad Dog McCree my
name is Robert greevey and I was the CEO
of American Laser games this is the aha
moment actually looking at this picture
I realized that there was a potential to
turn this simulator into a video game so
that became Mad Dog Mad Dog McCree the
team now had the technology to make a
video game but what they needed was a
story being located in New Mexico the
Wild West was an obvious choice and they
didn't have to go too far to find their
stars
[Music]
my name is Ross Dillon and I played mad
dog retreat I lived in New Mexico all my
life I was born and raised here on this
ranch I've been out here 60 years we
start shooting that nobody who Mad Dog
was or who it was gonna be Bob greevey
decided I would make a good Mad Dog
obviously not for my looks probably was
because I could quick draw that's pretty
quick in those days
finding a Mad Dog who could quick-draw
was easy but transforming a blond-haired
blue-eyed Rancher into a
rough-and-tumble outlaw from the Wild
West that's a different story I guess
the most time-consuming part was the
makeup and the hair stuff and that hair
guy's a mess
if I'd sweat you know we're doing this
and being black stuff rolling down my
forehead when I saw him at first dressed
as Mad Dog I had no clue it was my
husband it was kind of like looking at
somebody else I was dressed in the
buggery thing black and that horrid
orange scarf it looks almost like a
carnival thing but I guess that became
the trademark of Mad Dog was that orange
scarf the plot of Mad Dog McCree goes
something like this a gain of Outlaws
has laid claim to a small-town
kidnapping the mayor and his daughter
the players job is to kill the members
of the gang and eventually Mad Dog
himself
freeing the town from terror
because players competed against live
actors in the game the biggest challenge
was accounting for unpredictability the
crew had to shoot each scene in a way
that allowed for multiple outcomes of
the same situation we've got four people
in the shot who does a players shoot
first
oh my shoots number one first well what
if he shot number four first well we've
got to film that too one scene alone I'm
probably four different people I'm one
of the guy jumps out in the street and
tries to shoot it and then as you're
walking up the street to the saloon me
and they all come out fighting it was
pretty corny you know but yeah there's
always a you know special place for Mad
Dog because because of water was and
what it became
we didn't know if the game would be a
success we didn't know if the product
would work or not I mean it was
on-the-job training for all of us it's
hard to see the light shining so bright
it really exploded instantly in
popularity worldwide because nobody had
ever seen anything like it you've had
you couldn't hardly get near again
because it was just so popular
[Music]
I really appreciate just how much that
we accomplished back 20 years ago I
never really thought the mad dog would
have a legacy but its iconic and that it
really sort of represented this moment
of time when video gaming went from pong
and pac-man to Grand Theft Auto you know
I think it was a wonderful stepping
stone for the industry
[Music]